My brother flew all the way out from Germany to be with us in London
for less than 48 hours
so that lucky and I can go to the Burberry show together.
The jet lag has been hitting me hard.
I can barely get out of bed,
but I put my alarm in the other room,
so I literally am forced to.
Luckily, whimsy was still sleeping when we got up.
We let her sleep, hopped in the shower,
did our skincare, and ordered some breakfast.
I'm usually not hungry in the mornings,
but lucky got these really good waffles I can't say no to.
And right as we were wrapping up breakfast,
whimsy woke up, and then my brother got in.
He was on whimsy duty pretty much all day long.
Right after he got there, the Burberry team got there,
and the Vogue team got there.
Today felt so exciting since we were shooting a Vogue video
while we were getting ready for the Burberry show.
My makeup, we went with a very 90s,
simple makeup look. And for my hair,
we went with a very fun updo that was more of an undone type situation.
And since lucky was mic'd up,
I helped him get dressed,
and then he went over and shot his last little shots.
Lindsay obviously needed to come say hi to everyone,
since she's very social. So after she did that,
lucky helped me get into my outfit.
Once we were done shooting The video.
We had to rush out the door
since we were gonna run late on the way to the venue.
Lucky got so tired that he just fell asleep right before we got there.
I woke him up.
I always get pretty nervous before getting out of the car
because there's so many people taking pictures and videos
and yelling at you. Once that part is done,
we went inside to find our seats,
and it's always nice to see familiar faces,
and the show was absolutely stunning.